[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
en Filipinas una isla que busca pasar
del terrorismo al turismo
Hollow es una pequeña isla del Pacífico
en el extremo sur del archipiélago de
Filipinas durante mucho tiempo fue
inaccesible pero no por razones
geográficas o climáticas sino porque era
el bastión de uno de los movimientos
terroristas más violentos del mundo
llamado
entre asesinatos secuestros piratería
extorsión este grupo islamista nació en
los años 90 y tenía un método de
ejecución representativo la decapitación
con sable
abusayab reivindicaba oficialmente la
creación de un estado isla en el sur de
Filipinas en Francia se descubrió su
existencia en el año 2000 por el
secuestro de un grupo de 20 turistas de
los cuales dos eran franceses fueron
raptados en Malasia luego a la isla de
huló las negociaciones duraron varios
meses antes de lograr su Liberación pero
ahora después de 30 años de combates con
el ejército filipino abusayaf está en
Vía de extinción y la isla está
volviendo a recuperar la paz los últimos
miembros de la organización se
replegaron y están escondidos en las
montañas y entre la selva el ejército
Afirma haber asegurado La Isla Y puso en
marcha un programa para ayudar a los
arrepentidos de abusayaf a reintegrarse
en la sociedad la isla ahora sueña con
ser un destino turístico Esta es la
historia
unas Islas paradisíacas atormentadas por
un demonio un demonio con rostro de niño
Sami tenía 10 años cuando fue reclutado
por abusayab
durante seis años hizo parte de una de
las bandas más violentas de este grupo
terrorista
estaba a cargo de cuidar a una
secuestrada que estaba embarazada acá
cuidado porque me daba lástima su madre
dijo que era demasiado pobre y que no
podía pagar el rescate
Incluso si mataban a su hija así me era
para mí
al cabo de un tiempo decidieron
golpearla a muerte
le dieron golpes le caminaron encima
[Música]
ella me miraba
me suplicaba
yo ya no podía enfrentarme a su mirada
al final
le vendaron los ojos y la de Capitán
y como si se cebara la mala suerte
[Música]
diez días antes de nuestra llegada la
joven esposa de Sami murió después de
haber dado a luz por complicaciones
durante el parto hecho en casa
su bebé también murió de una infección
[Música]
cuando ella estaba embarazada yo estaba
tan feliz
tan impaciente por ser padre
lloro con frecuencia
pienso que eso pasó por todo lo que hice
a partir de los años 70 el sur de
Filipinas fue arrasado por una
insurrección musulmana dejando más de
100.000 Muertos el centro de los
combates eran estas islas en los
confines de Malasia e Indonesia una
tierra de islam en medio de unas
filipinas católicas en nombre de esa
supuesta guerra Santa a partir de los
años 90 una facción radical llamada
abusaiaf puso bombas en un avión y
después en un ferry inicialmente
vinculada al qaeda la organización
convirtió a holó una isla de medio
millón de habitantes en su capital un
infierno que ningún extranjero se
atrevía a pisar
[Aplausos]
desde las Islas vecinas esos voluntarios
traen Regalos y comida para los niños
que viven en los pueblos remotos de
Hollow una misión poco frecuente con
escoltas militares gracias a ellos nos
sentimos seguros
Sin ellos no sé seguramente No seríamos
lo suficientemente valientes como para
venir aquí
en julo los miembros de las
organizaciones humanitarias fueron
Víctimas de secuestro al igual que los
periodistas los militares nos
acompañarán durante toda la filmación de
este reportaje esta médico es la jefa de
los voluntarios
cuando me transfirieron aquí la
situación era terrible
el lugar al que vamos ahora los
militares no podían entrar
de lo contrario había inmediatamente una
emboscada con tiros no
durante más de 20 años esta selva estuvo
bajo el control de los islamistas de
abusaiah a comienzos de los años 2000
había más de 1000 combatientes oficiales
Su objetivo era fundar un estado
islámico en el sur de Filipinas
actualmente habría menos de unas centena
escondidos en la selva y estarían
inactivos según el ejército esta
Victoria anunciada con orgullo por las
autoridades se detuvo después de largos
años de combate en estos Valles aislados
del resto del país
dos tres
se construyeron carreteras para abrir el
paso aunque son pantanosas representan
un avance Respecto a los caminos en
medio de la selva que había en el pasado
Este capitán ha estado a cargo del Valle
Desde hace dos años un cristiano en
Campos musulmanes sin embargo rompía
Rosa creció en Arabia Saudita
Tratamos de sumar la fuerza de los
hombres a la fuerza del motor antes
estas personas le proporcionaban dinero
información y logística al grupo
abusayab pero ahora le ayudan a las
fuerzas gubernamentales Entonces no solo
estamos ganando la batalla estamos
ganando la guerra y la estamos ganando
con todas estas personas a nuestro
alrededor dejamos atrás a los
voluntarios para seguir a Este capitán
de 36 años su especialidad es crear
vínculos entre la población y el
ejército para mantener la seguridad a
largo plazo en las zonas pacificadas
[Música]
en el 2020 año del último ataque
registrado 11 militares murieron en este
pueblo una parte de sus 150 habitantes
huyó hace más de una década los demás se
quedaron pero vivían con miedo como esta
mujer de 54 años la jefa del pueblo
la mayoría de las casas tenían estas
barricadas cuando los militantes de
abusa yaf venían aquí para
nuestras mujeres y nuestros hijos
escondían en la mezquita en nuestros
hombres se ponían detrás de estos muros
para resguardarse del fuego cruzado
para ver esta barricada me da
escalofríos
pero la paz llegó hace tan solo unos
meses entonces Todavía mantengo mi
barricada
desde hace tres meses los habitantes
desplazados por el conflicto han
regresado a sus hogares se
reconstruyeron 35 casas gracias a una
ayuda de 380 dólares por vivienda
concebida por las autoridades la mayoría
de los habitantes afirman ser férreos
opositores de los yihadistas que
sembraron el terror a través de
secuestros constantes pero el capitán no
se deja engañar Aunque abusa ya defendía
una ideología islamista su influencia
dependía en gran medida de la pobreza de
estos Campos
ya te invito
estas personas fueron reclutadas
esencialmente por razones
socioeconómicas es lo que se conoce como
el concepto Robin Hood robarle a los
ricos para dárselo a los pobres si se
les roban millones a los ricos se les
puede dar dinero a las personas más
vulnerables a cambio esas personas le
ayudaban a abusayar lo que el gobierno
está haciendo ahora es contrarrestar ese
concepto convirtiéndose el mismo en un
Robin Hood más generoso para los
habitantes les ofrecemos unos medios de
vida sostenibles educación carretera
unir a la población pero también
convencer a los yihadistas de renunciar
a la lucha Esa es la otra prioridad del
ejército y para lograrlo el arma de los
soldados es la educación en este pueblo
no hubo escuela durante 21 años
actualmente hay 150 alumnos durante el
fin de semana hasta los padres de
familia asisten a clase entre ellos
también hay excombatientes arrepentidos
de abusayab
como este hombre con bandana un alumno
de 60 años
me da mucha vergüenza no sé leer ni
escribir ni siquiera conozco las letras
y me cuesta trabajo pronunciar las
palabras
Aunque cuando estaba en abusa y ya casi
todos los combatientes eran incapaces de
leer
a veces nos enseñaban El Corán
pero a mí eso no me interesaba
cultivador de plantas silvestres rado
dice que fue reclutado después de
haberse involucrado con los yihadistas
durante un enfrentamiento con los
soldados a partir de ahí estuvo 23 años
en la selva 23 años escondiéndose del
ejército
empezábamos a caminar en la mañana si
llovía había barro por todas partes y se
volvía difícil avanzar siempre estábamos
huyendo no podíamos vivir con nuestras
mujeres o con nuestros hijos Esa fue mi
vida pero ya no quiero seguir así Ahora
las autoridades se le han dado una
máquina que le permite transformar sus
plantas en cuerdas
El capitán Villa rusa trata de mantener
una relación Conrado y los otros cinco
excombatientes del pueblo hace una
comida entre antiguos enemigos
comíamos arroz medio cocinado y verduras
crudas para darle sabor lo único que
podíamos hacer era agregar sal si
encontrábamos un paquete de fideos
instantáneos hacíamos fiesta
un campesino que fue una víctima Esa es
la imagen quebrado quiere proyectar
difícil conocer la verdad lo que se sabe
es que los jefes de abu sayaf obtuvieron
millones de dólares a través de
múltiples secuestros una industria del
rapto que convirtió el movimiento
inicialmente ideológico en un grupo
infame en la zona que controlábamos
algunos Rehenes eran transportados y
vigilados por otros grupos la mayoría
eran Rehenes locales pero también había
filipinos de otras regiones y
extranjeros de Malasia o incluso
americanos no se podía mantener a Los
Rehenes en el mismo lugar eran
desplazados constantemente Los
Americanos una palabra genérica que se
usa aquí para Designar a cualquier
occidental los piratas de abusayab
terminaron por secuestrar tu que estaban
en las playas de los países vecinos
sembrando el terror en toda la región Y
afectando de forma sostenida el sector
del turismo en Filipinas esas acciones
hicieron pública a la organización que
en 2014 le juró lealtad al estado
islámico
[Música]
unos combatientes extranjeros vinieron a
juntarse con nosotros unos árabes
rezaban cinco veces al día y estaban
realmente determinados a combatir a
morir por la causa también había una
mujer una combatiente que usaba el jiyab
y unos adolescentes
el sueño de errado es poder enviar a sus
hijos a trabajar en Arabia Saudita en la
capital de La Isla hoy en día han cesado
los secuestros los militares siguen
alertas pero la mayoría de los
habitantes consideran que los años
oscuros quedaron atrás
[Música]
sin embargo aún hay una comunidad que
todavía desconfía mayoría en Filipinas
los cristianos aquí solo representan el
1% de la población en enero de 2019 en
plena misa de domingo los kamikasas
detonaron sus explosivos en la catedral
el ataque de joven 23 muertos y más de
100 heridos
regresamos a la selva
los voluntarios de la asociación
Children Of War lograron llegar a este
pueblo remoto estás contenta de que haya
vuelto
sí es genial cuando vienes
500 niños que habitan en zonas
antiguamente controladas por abusayaz
recibirán ayudas una fiesta escasa en
estos pueblos dominados durante años por
el fundamentalismo y la pobreza
[Música]
nos encontramos con el capitán Villa
Rosa y sus hombres con uniformes un poco
más festivos ha venido Incluso un
oficial de alto Rango
cristiano aunque seamos cristianos Somos
musulmanes chinos o extranjeros
la fuerza de nuestra religión es la
cohesión social y la diversidad cultural
[Aplausos]
es genial ver a todos estos niños y
pensar que ya nos llevarán armas si el
objetivo es que haya paz hay que empezar
por los niños esa es una frase de
Mahatma Gandhi
Habrá Paz definitiva en holó las
autoridades están convencidas en
septiembre pasado la Marina compuesta
por los comandos de élite a cargo de la
lucha contra buzayab se retiró de la
región los oficiales del ejército sueñan
con un futuro turístico para esta Isla
malherida se inventaron un eslogan
Hollow del terrorismo al turismo pero
para que los turistas se atrevan a venir
primero será necesario que haya largos
años de paz
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta desde filipinas
visitamos donde tras años de violencia
la población anhela un futuro turístico
para su Isla recuerde que puede Ingresar
a nuestra página web France 24.com para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores hasta
la próxima